todos nós pensamos e acho que sem
exceção que sabemos as razões das nossas
ações
tema que me traz aqui é algo com o qual
é um tema com o qual nós temos muita
intimidade na verdade temos muitas mas
muitas instituições sobre aquilo que
explica as nossas ações
sabemos sem dúvida alguma porque
compramos e ortiz e na urt y porque
escolhemos um carro a e não ver porque
escolhemos ser fiéis ou infiéis porque
pronto porque estamos aqui e não lá fora
em nome disso criamos nome dessa certeza
de que somos de facto pessoas racionais
pessoas que sabem o que fazem
criamos modelos modelos explicação de
previsão da ação humana
esses modelos em várias organizações as
famílias e as escolas por exemplo na
organização
é muito comum que há em um conjunto
enorme de incentivos para que as pessoas
sejam produtivas eficazes e eficientes e
efetivas e muitos desses incentivos
econômicos incentivos materiais de toda
ordem depois pedem que as pessoas sejam
impactadas que as pessoas colaborem
partilhem tem alguma coisa estranha que
você pega aquela sejam seja
absolutamente racionais uma série de
estímulos para ela depois fala não seja
simpático simpático seja absolutamente
colaborativa e participativo
compartilhem informação
só que as pessoas têm obviamente
interesses e objetivos e seguem
instrumentalmente essas obras a mesma
coisa nas escolas
nós criamos escolas modelos pedagógicos
modelos escola que privilegiam apenas o
quase só o desempenho de novos soldados
estilos é a nota é o quadro de honra
a nada essa moto de uma outra discussão
mas o som os rankings e assim por diante
as pessoas seguem esses estímulos segue
racionalmente assistimos os pais modo os
filhos de alguma forma para o sucesso ou
insucesso frio reprimido triste que é
está única e exclusivamente ligado
aquilo que as organizações querem e
aquilo que as escolas que é jovem pais
dizendo coloquem do filho nessa ou
naquela escola ele tem que estar
treinando para competir no mercado de
trabalho tem 56 anos é uma baita de uma
sacanagem
esse modelo é um modelo que é um
liberdade chamar o modelo handebol que é
como vocês conhecem não é é um é um
ponto é um psicopata
nós temos criados psicopatas tempo todas
as nossas instituições nas nossas casas
e nas organizações
este é na verdade um grande movimento
ideológico os últimos tempos
quantos de vocês se lembram eu incluo
aqui como eu preparei a top eu me lembro
mas quantos de vocês se lembram e 50
pessoas que morreram sufocados num
caminhão na alça outras pessoas se
lembram de centenas de pessoas que têm
morrido no mediterrâneo em busca de
refúgio
provavelmente como muito saliente ainda
essa informação alguns de vocês vão se
lembrar mas a pergunta que faço quem se
lembra desse neutro e se quase todos
vocês se lembram se não todos
essa imagem forte e ficou muito forte
porque a imprensa colocou toda a
imprensa colocou na primeira página e
nós só depois desta foto divulgação
dessa foto de facto ficamos
sensibilizados com uma questão
humanitária que já tinha
vitimado centenas milhares de pessoas
nos últimos anos
isso é novo o tema dos refugiados antigo
mas nós ficamos sensibilizados com um
caso o ws mall
o investigador da universidade da
pensilvânia da horta moscou é de um nome
é isso de efeito da vítima identificável
nós na economia comportamental criamos
experiências que os seres humanos mas
são experiências comportamentais ou seja
não não são invasivas são apenas
comportamentais e neste caso criamos
dois grupos o grupo a que as pessoas
recebiam um papel no qual tinha a
seguinte informação quanto você estaria
disponível a doar para a rockwell que é
uma miúda do mali
uma menina de 7 anos que não têm
condições de se alimentar não tem
condições dignas para viver e quer muito
estudar quanto você daria as pessoas
recebiam dinheiro e doavam logo a seguir
a quantidade desejada
um outro grupo equilibrado em termos de
sexo em termos de idade recebia uma
outra dieta uma outra a um outro texto
que dizia existem três milhões de
crianças de aproximadamente sete anos
que vivem numa linha sem condições o
resto do texto é idêntico ao da roc
idêntico fica obviamente eu vou fazer
enquanto que as pessoas doaram o caso
identificado de rock quanto as pessoas
doaram o caso estatístico vamos chamar
assim como teria como dizer sem uma
teoria chama do caso os três milhões de
crianças
a teoria da escolha racional que a
teoria da escolha é hegemônica ainda
diria que aqui se você doa x para uma
criança você tem que doar x vezes alguma
coisa para 3 milhões de crianças estão
no limite nós doamos a mesma quantidade
porque afinal de contas
eu tenho nos bons eu tenho dois euros
vou doar do euro seja para uma criança
ou pra 3 milhões de crianças o que
aconteceu não foi isso
curiosamente as pessoas ou muito menos
três milhões de crianças do que para uma
única criança há uma simetria de empatia
e essa assimetria de empatia é tão
poderosa que nós podemos ser mais ou
menos indiferentes à genocídios por
exemplo milhões de pessoas são mortas
centenas milhares de pessoas são mortas
nós olhamos falando ok ok obviamente não
fizemos assim
isso realmente não o ps3 mas quando
morre uma criança nós ficamos e se for
identificada
nós ficamos muito tristes sentimos muita
empatia questão é nós somos ruins as
pessoas mas por causa disso
claro que não somos pessoas reais
a teoria de escolha racional a teoria da
racionalidade diz que isso é errado
na verdade essa empatia que nós sentimos
por uma única criança faz parte da nossa
natureza nós não somos maus por isso o
que explica essa simetria de empatia é a
nossa comissão
nós temos dois sistemas o primeiro é
muito básico que opera de forma rápida e
inconsciente e de forma intuitiva um
sistema
nós chamamos de sistema 2 que traz essa
informação de forma lenta consciente e
racional até 20 anos até 20 anos nós
achávamos que eram só o sistema 2
só que nós achávamos que éramos rápidos
e não lentos consciente racionais sempre
achados
a questão é que de facto grande parte da
nossa tomada de decisão das nossas
decisões das nossas escolhas são feitas
nesse nível 1 que é o mais básico que
nós partilhamos com os outros animais é
onde nós temos a intuição onde estão as
emoções onde está empatia assim por
diante
um exemplo muito curioso na escócia beta
é um investigador colocou numa empresa
numa pequena
porque havia a as pessoas tomavam leite
tomava um café e davam aquilo que
achavam que era justo tanto havia uma
certa confiança naquilo que as pessoas
doavam supostamente para este convívio
para esse café com leite tomar um lanche
e assim por diante
uma primeira semana eles colocaram olhos
uma segunda semana uma imagem de flores
na terceira semana uma imagem de olhos
na quarta semana uma imagem de flores e
assim sucessivamente até a 10ª semana de
tal forma que as pessoas quando entravam
não viu ela não tinham acesso a essa
imagem diretamente não ficava em cima da
máquina ficava discretamente colocada e
no final da experiência nenhum dos
participantes disse que tinha visto essa
imagem
pronto o que acontece
nós processamos a informação pelo
sistema 11 de forma inconsciente
o que vocês acham que aconteceu como eu
dei a dica que vocês podem imaginar o
que aconteceu com os pagamentos que
aconteceu foi o seguinte nas semanas com
óleos discretamente colocadas as pessoas
pagarão muito mais deram muito mais
dinheiro do que as semanas com flores
o que acontece quando esse exemplo que
as pessoas merecem um na minha empresa
tem lá um problema vou meter lá olhos
o que acontece de fato isso não vai
funcionar e isso tem que ser adaptado
isso é só pra mostrar que o sistema um
funciona funciona de fato as pessoas
naquele dia tomaram leite tomaram café e
pensar assim hoje uma das 57 anos porque
é racional dar 50 cent não mudar 70
cêntimos porque é racional dessa terça 7
mas na verdade as pessoas tinham sido
sido influenciadas pelos olhos e pelas
fotos não significa que a decisão tenha
como causa única e exclusivamente os
olhos e as flores mas certamente em
média as pessoas foram influenciadas a
tomada de decisões por conta desse
processamento no sistema
numa outra experiência adeptos mall
voltando essa minha colega queria
mostrar uma coisa muito curiosa
nós achamos que incentivar as pessoas
não falam só das organizações mas fala
de modo geral como já dei no início da
tarde alguns exemplos incentivar as
pessoas economicamente é materialmente a
melhor forma e ela tentou verificar se
de fato em todos os casos os
funcionários que ela fez foi novamente
criar dois grupos num dos grupos
ela pedia às pessoas gravação em vídeo
de 60 segundos mais ou menos pedindo
doações para uma determinada causa
só que as pessoas não eram incentivados
materialmente não eram incentivados
economicamente de forma elas faziam
aquilo com sinceridade porque
acreditavam na causa
no grupo b ela dizia olha a causa fish
vocês vão fazer isso as pessoas na claro
faço com todo prazer mas ela dizia assim
olha você vai receber 10% do valor doado
a cada dez dólares você recebe um roupa
ok vamos lá fazem os vídeos 60 segundos
pois foi feita uma análise de conteúdo
dos discursos eram claramente parecidos
não havia nenhuma assimetria entre esses
cursos internos semânticos o que
aconteceu foi que esses vídeos foram
levados com a plataforma e outras
milhares de pessoas
assistimos vídeos e ficava ou não
tocados por aquela causa e doavam ou não
se quisessem obviamente o que aconteceu
foi o seguinte que o grupo os vídeos das
pessoas que não tinham sido incentivadas
conseguiu muito mais doações do que os
grupos que o grupo das pessoas que tinha
das pessoas que tinham sido incentivadas
ou seja as pessoas do outro lado que
assistiram os vídeos e que queriam ou
não doar de tomar uma decisão que
conseguiram detectar não batota porque
não era o caso mas a falta de
sinceridade incentivo econômico retirou
das pessoas é uma posição importante que
era a alma da mensagem às pessoas ao dar
a mensagem podiam ser eficazes iam ser
efetivas queriam fazer com que as outras
pessoas são tocadas retirando a
sinceridade perdeu a alma completamente
a mensagem
o fato é que esses são dados de uma
experiência que foi feita com centenas
de pessoas depois que milhares de
doadores está publicada numa revista
científica de altíssimo nível mas nós
ainda realmente não damos a devida o
devido valor
mas isso tem mudado porque depois da
publicação de um livro em 1990 em 2008
desculpa do registo da educação existem
chama nerd que é nerd é um neologismo
fica empurrãozinho
nós podemos usar esse conhecimento que
temos sobre cognição humana sobre a
tomada de decisão para ajudar as pessoas
a a agirem de uma maneira de se
comportar de maneira mais positiva pelas
próprias em termos coletivos também e aí
essa imagem de elefante é a mãe ou pai
dando um pouquinho por um vizinho no
elefante bebê pra que ele se movimente
se comporta de maneira adequada têm sido
tão importante e em alguns momentos nós
podemos utilizar essas empurrãozinho pra
fazer com que as pessoas joguem coisas
no lixo ou que faça xixi no lugar certo
os homens prontos sabem que é uma
diversão acertar ali o buraquinho mas
tendo um campo assim um golzinho fica
feliz né
é mais interessante
isso é tão poderoso que governos de
linhagens diferentes o obama liberal do
ponto de vista das políticas sociais
liberal e o cameron conservador
o próprio banco mundial tem reconhecido
a economia comportamental ea ciência do
comportamento que ali a economia
neurociência e psicologia seja cognitivo
social experimental em muitas outras
áreas inclusive em antropologia formando
grupos multidisciplinares que trabalham
sobre o comportamento tanto nesses dores
governos existem agências que trabalham
as políticas públicas só do ponto de
vista comportamental
a idéia do elefante tocando o
elefantinho me parece muito interessante
para mostrar quanto o comportamento é
relevante nas vidas de todos nós
relevantes nas vidas dos nossos filhos
das pessoas que estão nas escolas sejam
os professores dos alunos das pessoas
que estão um sofrimento organizacional
ou seja as pessoas sofrem dentro das
organizações
porque eles é cobrada uma determinada
nacionalidade que não é do ponto de
vista cognitivo possível até parecer
estranho mas relaxa
ou seja não estou dizendo vamos sair por
aí todos irracionais
vamos fazer coisas malucas e assim por
diante a idéia realmente não é essa a
ideia é aceitar as pessoas os seres
humanos
do ponto de vista da racionalidade da
produção como essas pessoas são como nós
somos
não adianta cobrar das pessoas aquilo
que elas não podem dar lhe a pergunta
filosófica é será se pudessem dar seria
a melhor coisa nesse momento acho que
podemos pensar quando fomos comprar um
eu gosto quando formos
de qual a qual vai ser a nossa própria
próxima viagem se os nossos governantes
pensam ou não em termos comportamentais
podemos neste momento pensar será que o
sistema um que funciona será que o
sistema 2 que tem funcionamento será que
eu sou tão racional assim será que eu
devo procurar mais informação
ou será que de facto é impossível
processar toda aquela quantidade enorme
de informação de modo racional
tanto o movimento aqui é cobrar dessas
instituições e cobrar das organizações
que construam políticas sejam
organizacionais sejam públicas adaptadas
a nós seres humanos normais e comuns